[Música]
es conocida como la nación del arco iris
por su gran diversidad de culturas
idiomas y religiones tan solo su
constitución reconoce como oficiales ni
más ni menos que 11 idiomas diferentes
por supuesto hablamos de sudáfrica un
país que tal y como indica su nombre
está situado en el extremo sur de áfrica
no hablamos de un país pequeñito su
superficie es mayor que la suma de
alemania francia italia bélgica y los
países bajos casi nada
por otro lado sudáfrica es con
diferencia la economía más desarrollada
de todo el áfrica sub-sahariana y en
2010 fue además el primer país africano
en acoger un mundial de fútbol
y lo hizo al ritmo del waka waka de
shakira y desde luego los españoles lo
tenemos muy presente de verdad por
primera vez ganamos la copa del mundo
gracias a ese histórico gol de iniesta
en el descuento
[Música]
pues bien el mes más importante de la
historia de este país fue abril de 1994
entre los días 26 y 29 de dicho mes se
celebraron las primeras elecciones
democráticas libres y universales de la
historia de este país si no me equivoco
las elecciones duraron cuatro días y
durante este tiempo los sudafricanos
salieron masivamente a votar las colas
fueron kilométricas
no era para menos estos comicios
pusieron fin a 300 años de colonialismo
y supremacía blanca estas elecciones
significaban para siempre el fin del
apartheid el apartheid y el apartheid
fue un terrible sistema de segregación
racial que estuvo en vigor durante casi
50 años fundamentalmente consistía en
separar a la población blanca de la
población negra tanto para vivir
estudiar o pasar el tiempo libre por
supuesto ya os lo podéis imaginar todas
las mejores zonas y los mejores
servicios eran para los blancos un buen
ejemplo son las ambulancias a pesar de
que los negros representaban el 80 por
ciento de la población apenas tenían
ambulancias en cambio las ambulancias
para blancos eran numerosas pero se
negaban a llevar personas negras porque
la ley les amparaba
e
en la parte les otorgaba a los blancos
todo el poder político y además fijaba
muchísimas restricciones precisamente
para consolidar el poder blanco por
ejemplo los matrimonios e incluso las
relaciones mixtas estaban
terminantemente prohibidas de facto el
apartheid relegada a la población negra
que era insisto la gran mayoría a una
condición no humana
[Música]
así había dos gráficas muy distintas una
la negra terriblemente pobre y otra la
blanca muy rica y claro la represión y
los castigos contra quienes se revelaban
eran por supuesto también terribles el
16 de junio de 1976 miles de estudiantes
negros se manifestaron para pedir
mejoras sociales y educativas y cientos
de ellos fueron masacrados el sueño de
mandela pero en 1994 todo cambió y lo
hizo de la mano del que hoy es
considerado el padre de este país nelson
mandela también conocido popularmente
como madiba mándela fue un líder en la
lucha contra la pared y el racismo un
activismo que le costó muy caro en 1961
fue condenado por traición a cadena
perpetua mándela se pasó los siguientes
27 años en la cárcel hasta 1992 eso sí
dos años más tarde en las elecciones de
1994 fue elegido presidente de sudáfrica
el primer presidente negro del país
[Música]
para sorpresa de muchos su apuesta no
fue la venganza sino la reconciliación
mándela soñaba con una sudáfrica libre
unida y próspera algo que quedó muy
claro en su discurso de investidura ha
llegado el momento de curar las heridas
el momento de salvar los abismos que nos
dividen nos ha llegado el momento de
construir con traemos el compromiso de
construir una sociedad en la que todos
los sudafricanos tanto negros como
blancos puedan caminar con la cabeza
alta sin ningún miedo en el corazón
seguros de contar con el derecho
inalienable a la dignidad humana
mándela a diferencia de tantos otros
cumple su palabra trabajo por una
sudáfrica cohesionada y cuando llegó el
momento con los límites marcados en la
constitución dejó el poder y se hizo a
un lado eso le convirtió en un verdadero
mito what is revés y sobre el pasado es
el pasado
hay que mirar al futuro por cierto un
apunte importantísimo amigos cuando
hablamos de un país nunca jamás
pretendemos desprestigiarlo todo lo
contrario los que nos seguís desde hace
tiempo sabéis que nos gusta viajar
conocer diferentes culturas y que
soñamos pues con un mundo más abierto y
menos barreras digo todo esto porque
cuando recientemente publicamos el vídeo
en el que denunciamos la terrible
situación por la que atraviesa el
salvador algunos de vosotros nos
escribiste diciéndonos que a lo mejor
esto podía ser malo para el país no lo
creemos en absoluto el salvador es una
bellísima tierra pero ahora mismo
atraviesa un momento difícil eso es una
realidad en visual política estamos
convencidos de que para poder ser
resuelto el problema tiene que conocerse
y denunciarse tanto a nivel local como
internacional de todas formas también lo
sabéis aunque somos optimistas con el
mundo en que vivimos publicamos vídeos
con diferentes enfoques algunos son
positivos y otros negativos porque en la
vida pues no todos color de rosas
pero volvamos a sudáfrica el único país
del mundo que no tiene una sola capital
lo que tiene es ciudad del cabo en la
capital del poder legislativo pretoria
el poder ejecutivo y blomfontein la del
poder judicial y por si fuese poco
amigos davis al político en la ciudad
más grande y donde se concentran todos
los negocios no es ninguna de las tres
sino una cuarta johannesburgo
así que sí que no se extrañe que ni
siquiera los libros de texto de los
colegios se pongan nunca de acuerdo pues
bien tras la caída del régimen del
apartheid sudáfrica vivió un despegue
notable desde el 94 el tamaño de la
economía real teniendo en cuenta la
capacidad de compra se ha triplicado
[Música]
la pobreza se ha reducido con mucha
fuerza y cientos de miles de familias
negras se integran cada año en la clase
media la violencia aunque sigue siendo
muy alta porque sudáfrica es un país
peligroso se ha reducido y en general el
acceso al agua potable la electricidad o
la sanidad también han mejorado
muchísimo por poner casos sudáfrica es
la gran potencia turística y también
financiera de áfrica sub sahariana tiene
la mayor bolsa de todo el continente e
incluso ojo es una potencia la industria
automovilística empresas como volkswagen
bmw nissan general motors ford
mercedes-benz o toyota tiene aquí
fábricas de montaje suena todo bien
verdad pues desgraciadamente las cosas
hoy no pintan tan bien crisis y
estancamiento a pesar de los logros
cosechados la economía sudafricana lleva
prácticamente estancada desde 2009 la
economía no crece el desempleo es de los
más altos del mundo y en general trabaja
muy poquita gente fijaros el país tiene
unos 55 millones de habitantes pero sólo
15 tienen trabajo y muchos de ellos
encima trabajos informales además la
inversión de las empresas
cayendo nueve años su moneda en rne se
ha devaluado muchísimo y la deuda
pública está a punto de ser declarada
como 'bonos basura' vamos todo un
desastre de hecho en los últimos años
las rentas más altas están literalmente
escapando del país pero claro os
preguntaréis qué diantres ha ocurrido
[Música]
jacob zuma este señor es de consuma el
presidente desde 2009 y su mandato ha
sido como decir lo desastroso solo para
que os hagáis una idea este señor se
enfrenta ante la justicia
atentos a 783 casos de corrupción vamos
todo un profesional a la hora de meter
la mano en el complejo de edificios que
su residencia suma ha invertido 16
millones y medio de euros en reformas
que hizo pasar como gastos de seguridad
entre ellos un establo para vacas un
corral para apoyos una piscina y un
anfiteatro pero no sólo eso el señor
zuma decidió apostar por políticas que
hacen huir en desbandada a la inversión
extranjera por ejemplo favoreciendo las
expropiaciones las cuales ha hecho por
ley más fáciles y baratas por cierto
esto que está sonando nos lo ha mandado
happy creeps un grupo formado por unos
estudiantes de ciencias políticas de la
universidad pablo olavide de sevilla
si tienes un grupo de música y quieres
que aparezca en el canal te dejamos la
información de cómo hacerlo en la
descripción pero volviendo a sudáfrica
el presidente jacob zuma también ha
convertido en la regulación laboral en
una traba casi insalvable para la
contratación precisamente su última
medida ha sido subir muchísimo el
salario mínimo en un país donde muy poca
gente trabaja de hecho muchos analistas
critican la medida diciendo que es un
disparate fijar un salario mínimo
superior al salario de casi la mitad de
los trabajadores vamos a ver todos
queremos que los haberes suban pero para
lograrlo habrá que generar primero la
riqueza no os parece si no se genera
empleo con salarios mucho más bajos
imaginaros ahora los problemas de
sudáfrica son otros y entre ellos
destaca con fuerza su horrible sistema
educativo
[Música]
el desastroso sistema educativo el
sistema educativo de sudáfrica es
malísimo para que os hagáis una idea uno
de cada tres estudiantes que han ido a
la escuela durante seis años tiene
problemas para leer y solo uno de cada
100 estudiantes negros logra hacer una
ingeniería todo esto es un problema
porque afecta al emprendimiento y porque
las empresas tienen dificultades para
encontrar mano de obra cualificada y no
es una cuestión de dinero
sudáfrica es uno de los países que en
términos relativos más invierte en
educación en el mundo
ahora
entonces qué ocurre pues muchos dicen
que la culpa está en que el sindicato de
docentes demócratas que controla el
sistema público se ha convertido en una
verdadera mafia el sindicato es
curiosamente aliado del presidente de
zuma y además de terminar con las
inspecciones educativas ha enchufado a
tanta gente que hoy la formación de los
profesores está por los suelos
hace unos años se hizo un test a los
profesores de matemáticas de niños de 11
y 12 años pues bien el resultado fue que
8 de cada 10 profesores obtuvieron un
resultado peor que el que se esperaba de
sus alumnos como para enseñar la verdad
que aquí no se salva ni el propio
presidente de sus presiones
camps y sus seis serán destinados en
esta línea fernández insistió nine
hundred en essex y nine
tauscher echando en tuenti
[Aplausos]
por supuesto los resultados para los
blancos que van a colegios privados son
bastante diferentes hay herencias del
apartheid que aún no se han superado
[Música]
conflicto racial por si fuese poco en
los últimos años se está recrudeciendo
los enfrentamientos raciales en 2013 se
creó el partido combatientes la libertad
económica que hoy ya es la tercera
fuerza política del país miembros de
este partido radical defienden casi
invertir lo que era el apartheid y
aplicárselo a los blancos su fuerza aún
es pequeña pero como elementos de
desestabilización
os podéis imaginar en fin hoy por hoy
podemos decir que el sueño de nelson
mandela corre peligro bueno y tú qué
opinas conseguirás sudáfrica hacer
realidad el sueño de madiba podrá este
país volver a hacer la nación más
próspera y libre de toda áfrica o tal
vez por el contrario el odio la
desconfianza y las malas políticas harán
de este país poco más que un sueño
pasajero espero vuestras respuestas en
los comentarios si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante y quieres que
hablemos más de áfrica
no olvides darle a light y por supuesto
si aún no lo has hecho suscríbete al
canal para recibir nuestros nuevos
vídeos por cierto si quieres descubrir
cómo está cambiando este continente no
os podéis perder este vídeo un saludo y
hasta la próxima